my talk is about reactive data
processing in Python
um I I would like to introduce you to
the topic of working with theming data
in a reactive way
so if you're concerned about uh writing
writing a program which performs some
let's say machine learning task
the way you will approach it most
probably is to write some code go to
type some code probably using the python
stack with pandas with some let's say
classifier which is used which is saying
which is used for prediction
who want to run some experiments with it
make sure it's working and be done with
it have a coffee
so this is the optimistic version of the
things start to get difficult if you
want to go to the streaming world to
start handling live data updates
this means essentially redoing all the
code logic we started out with in a
streaming architecture which means
preparing to handle every imaginable and
unimaginable data update scenario so all
this has to be done in conjunction with
classification and prediction logic
which was uh which was designed
previously and this is not an ideal
place to be
some of the joys of streaming data well
first of all data updater full of
surprises you may start out assuming
that we just need to handle new data
points as they arrive and we're done
with it but after a while it turns out
that many more update scenarios have to
be foreseen
so we have questions like day 77 hey
could we please update all the data
points that have arrived in the last
hour they have broken somebody entered a
feature which was called distance m in
Miles instead of meters so we have to
update all the data and what's worse our
models have already got date on that
data so we will need to unlearn that and
learn a new services like point one
point two uh the world of theming is
full of unknown unknowns so imagine that
for the last let's say week or longer
your program has been running in
streaming mode uh taking data in
overtime churning on data that it has
never seen before as the software
developer you cannot restart it you
cannot easily look inside your program
to see what it's actually doing you're
not quite sure what state it is in and
how it got there
and today things started to go wrong and
let's say one of our models seems to be
misclassifying or at least suspiciously
classifying all objects it sees as cow
what do you do now you cannot look into
it exactly well the answer is you cannot
do too much you can hope that perhaps
everything you're seeing today is really
is cows but maybe things are very wrong
so this is just 0.2
0.3 is all about data consistency so
suppose we go for something ambitious we
are deploying in production a system
which is doing live temperature
monitoring for a power plant
and now a number of uh interesting data
points have arrived the system is
processing them and in the last half
minute the critical alert flag has been
flashing on and off on and off at least
a dozen times as the system processes
data now it seems to be off so the
question is is it that our system is
already done with Computing and we can
um sigh with relief or do we wait just a
minute longer to be on the safe side and
ensuring consistency or not having
consistency is one of the bigger pain
points in in Steam data processing
so these worries are actually so
off-putting that some projects fall back
on batch execution which means they
pre-architecture which was designed to
be running a live in streaming never is
never put into place we say instead okay
I will instead of trying to update my
program as it is running I will just
rerun every say 30 minutes for batch
prototype which I wrote in pandas maybe
in paisberg to make it scale a bit
better on all the data that we've seen
so far at least this will work
so this is indeed a viable approach in
the sense that it's a fallback which may
just possibly work and here's a
checklist of things to check
um if it really does work so first of
all latency will the realm complete fast
enough to meet business needs in this
case is 30 minutes enough
secondly Computing cost so if we do have
a chance to rerun within the required
latency say within 30 minutes from
sketch how many cores will it take it
can easily go in thousands of calls
what's the cost of a cloud resources
needed to do that
point three this is an interesting one
reproducibility so suppose I'm
re-running my machine learning algorithm
or my pipeline every 30 minutes every
time I get subtly different results they
can be subtly different in an
unimportant way for example over rows
got renumbered and the last next time I
look at my outcomes were completely
different let's say up to permutation
with respect to the previous time is
this an issue or not
and finally future proofing if things
run fast enough today will they be
running fast enough in half a year or
one year from now the data will only be
becoming bigger as we go along
so this is a checklist of things to look
out for before we can actually fall back
to a batch processing system
the the issue the outcome the sad
realization seems to be that a lot of
industrial projects that we see that we
encounter on a day-to-day basis and
Enterprise uh fail to check at least one
box but nonetheless they choose to
deploy in batch mode delivering only
partial value
so it turns out that the barrier to
deliver steaming data projects in
production is just too high and the
tooling is missing so V industry Ops for
second best losing out on all the value
that streaming can offer
so
one thing one approach which comes to
the rescue is what we will focus on
today reactive design
the essence of reactive design is to
uncouple logic designed by the software
developer by the developer of a machine
learning model from data updates which
are going on in the system
as for developer you focus on describing
your logic as you would for a batch
system
and you let the reactive framework
behind the scenes handle all the data
stream processing and propagate all
changes
so if
for anybody who's used especially I
guess that means all of us uh the
separation is pretty clear if we are
programming or coding in a in a
spreadsheet all we do is Define the
logic declare the logic let's say we
want to cell B1 to be the sum of cells
A1 and A2 and we put up this rule
and we let the spreadsheet underneath
take all the data updates that are going
on let's say different values are
appearing three five two things are
changing uh and the spreadsheet takes
curves
so first battery do we know what this
means today my objective will be to
explain to show you what if this means
for a machine learning Pipeline and when
working specifically in Python
specifically with data frames or tables
so let's start by preparing our first
machine learning model reactively
the goal is to show you the proof of
concept so I'm not going to be super
original here let's start with
classifying handwritten digits as a toy
example
The Twist is that retaining data that's
coming in is changing over time we see
at every time new digits coming in new
digits with with labels so new new
elements of a training set which is
forcing our model to adapt
so clearly I want the model to improve
as new training data becomes available
and this described like this this task
is like a bundled uh mess between uh
classification in the machine learning
sense and some kind of data processing
data update processing task because you
have training data that's changing over
time
let's take the reactive perspective and
see if we can somehow untangle the two
issues and the the way to look at it is
like super straightforward we ask us ask
ourselves first is time a feature in the
data is time a column for us which is
used by the classifier
so here we are looking at classifying
handwritten digits handwritten digits
have nothing to do with time so the
obvious answer is no
this gives us the happy part of the easy
path it means that machine learning
logic that we design shouldn't be
concerned with how the data changes over
time it should just think badge act as
it would in fewer batch mode and let the
reactive framework take care of updating
the model as data changes
the other scenario which is not shown
here would be one more adapted to time
series let's skip it for the moment
cool example in pathway pathway is a
brand new framework uh programming
framework which has been tested in
Enterprise but which only today has
launched in open Beta is made available
to all developers so I'm happy to
publicly announce for the first time
code Snippets in pathway
and here's how you would write a
classifier for handwritten digits in
pathway it's basically three lines we
start by importing pathway uh you uh
load retaining data and the test data
that you want to work with so there's
like training uh data training labels
test data and test labels for the sake
of verification validation we loaded in
this case from a simulated data stream a
data stream of digits which represents
the mnist data set being steamed you
could connect as well to an external
data source
um you create a classifier container
classifier in this case we go for okay
nearest neighbors with lsh but for
details are not so important uh we we
set some parameters in this case by
almost like defaults plus Dimension
parameter
then we set the prediction
um meaning we want the predicted labels
to come from the classification using
the created classifier on the test data
set some further parameters and that's
basically it there's a final line which
allows us to validate and verify
accuracy and what what you see here
looks like a piece of code in Python it
is a piece of code in Python uh the
difference being that if we were to
execute this sort of code in batch mode
and imagine that it's like working in a
typical framework for all the lines here
would execute sequentially if it's just
done they'd produce some results
working with pathway in streaming mode
in production mode the outcome is
different the pathway distributed uh
runtime engine puts up or creates a kind
of control flow graph which describes
the lines that have been written and
puts it into place in the streaming
framework
so what you see in the lower part of
this slide in this image is the control
flow graph which has been put into place
we can say forever which will churn
Forever After the lines above have been
activated
data will be coming in from the input
data stream sources and again this may
maybe maybe something happening
perpetually
the the training data will be entering
retaining of the classifier and will
produce the classifier
together with the test data of the
classifier can be used for prediction to
generate for predicted labels
a final line which is commented out
allows us to validate the accuracy of of
a prediction based on test labels which
are also available
and
essentially
the if if you feel that there's no
difference between the code you tried to
run in batch mode and the code you write
in Pathway to deploy in streaming mode
then you you were right that's the
intention there's no such visible
difference it's just that the outcome is
completely different because in the
second mode in the streaming mode uh
Pathways engine takes care of processing
all the data updates so when a new
training element comes in with an update
to these two data streams which cause an
update to the classifier which may cause
an update to outcomes of protections and
pathway does it in the most resource
efficient way possible given the
implementation doing something known as
incremental computation which means that
only a part of the result is recomputed
a part of computations and hopefully for
this implementation just a very small
part of the whole of the whole picture
is recomputed with every new element of
data arriving
so this is for the way it works
um if we look at how pathway classifies
these classifying decisions for incoming
data so x-test in the previous slide
with the table of points for which
predictions are needed and these
predictions will be updated for as long
as obtained model changes if we get a
better model new elements coming in the
predictions will update themselves
uh the the idea here is that X test for
the test set can also be updated when we
need to take decisions on a given
element on a given data point we insert
it into the test set and if we no longer
to take need to take decisions we
deleted from the test set so to control
which decisions should be computed by
the system just to hold back one slide
we can actually add a pre-processing
step or a filtering step here or some
kind of control on the data Sim X test
before it goes into prediction to be
able to to control which predictions we
are interested in and in this way the
machine learning logic stays intact and
there's just a kind of filter on x-test
which tells us which predictions we
should be updating
uh what this means is that if we were to
imagine that we start streaming a
standard data set like the data in this
data set of handwritten digits as with
new training data coming in with new
test data coming in live uh the error
rate of the of the classifier used will
be reduced in time because as the
training set gets larger uh the other
rate will will drop up to up until it
drops to the theoretical level for for
the given classifier in this case about
five percent uh however pathway unless
of course we tell it not to but by
default pathway will be reclassifying
um updating decisions for the test
Elements which came early on in this
team which means that at the end of the
day if you look at the outcomes the
table of outcomes the table of
classification decisions made by pathway
the yellow rate will be uh consistently
low for all of the of for classified
elements so the ability to revisit
decisions revise decisions as the model
improves leads to a significant gain
with respect to just ad hoc decisions
like you only live once and you don't go
back on the data
a quick code primer for those of you
who've taken a shrine to this approach
in pathway tables think of tables think
of data frames we call from tables
either heart of everything you can
create a table by
um like from a static data source in
this case it'll be static forever in
this case we took a table just out of
the string hidden in markdown or you can
make a table out of the theme connector
so you can connect in the simplest case
to a directory of CSV files to a CSV
file which is updated over time and as
this streaming source is updated as the
input file is updated the table in
pathway is updated and over Machinery is
updated so this is something that that
can connect to uh to file data sources
in S3 it can connect to Kafka and other
data sources
so on top of tables we can learn table
operations for example we may want to
take our table in this case with a table
of dogs with known age and just filter
out all the dogs uh whose ages at most
10 and we can preview the outcome for
static data and if we were to do this in
streaming mode table dog Youngs would
would also automatically update in
streaming mode
um a slightly more operation is to do a
join in this case we can join in a
simple way dogs with their owners but
there are many many more advanced um
joints supported by a pathway and most
interestingly we can do functions on
tables uh let's suppose we would want to
correct the dog's age by subtracting one
from it we can make a map on on rows
using an apply function and get a table
which is uh which is appropriately
revised appropriately revised in the
publicly updated in real time a more
interesting and harder case which we
invite you to look at as as Transformer
classes which are much more expressive
and allow us to Define logic which is
much more powerful than just a simple
Lambda type transformation it's logic
which involves pointers to others and
potentially pointed to other tables
so um if you think about building if you
think about building a solution a
pipeline uh in in pathway
um the pipeline is composed of uh little
building blocks there like the the
orange ones uh here that are called
Transformers and which transform uh
tables into tables some tables input
tables into output tables
um if you take a data engineering
perspective then this type of pipeline
could make operations like filtering
tables joining tables doing a group
biogroup by reduce doing some kind of
sorting or scanning by sorted index Etc
now if we want to do
go beyond the data engineering and go
for machine learning then pathway makes
it possible to use what I would call A
Drop in replacement a smart replacement
for filter operation which is like
machine learning power so you can have a
machine learning filter which we call a
smart filter a join could be replaced
for example by a fuzzy join a fuzzy
matching a group by by a clustering or
classification operation which also
groups somehow the rows of the table a
sorted index by a machine learning
ranking Etc and you can build pipelines
of machine learning operations which
update like this
so you can make your own Transformers
using row pointers row centered logic as
well
um building and traversing lists and
graphs interestingly you can make loops
for example to make things iterate until
convergence and write compositional
logic
there's a pathway examples repo which
which is fully runnable which way
because you can test on codelab for
example where you can run a lot of
tutorial notebooks which you make
available
now for a quick demo
we've prepared an application which does
real-time Twitter sentiment analysis
with pathway
with geolocated tweets to figure out at
which geographical location has a given
topic is tending in a positive sense and
in which it's sending in a negative
sense
the application architecture which which
we are sharing with you which we invite
you to get it for more GitHub repo for a
direct link and which is runable with
Docker composers presented here
pathway takes in a real-time stream of
tweets collected via tweetly and then
runs it through logic within pathway
which I'll present to you in a minute
which makes use of python libraries
which are just code like that in pathway
connects through an output connector to
send its results out to a front end
which visualizes the results and these
results get updated in streaming Mode
live on the waivers also like a storage
and API layer which allows us to put
together the pieces so if you just allow
me to do a brief demonstration
I will move on to presenting my entire
screen
if you move into our GitHub repo you'll
receive it for the application is is all
there it comes with a number of Docker
composers I will show you how to do a
Docker replay
of
some some data that we collected after
music video awards but it's also
possible to achieve uh the same with a
different dock compose which we also
provide with live Twitter data so what
I'm showing you now is a streaming
replay of tweets that happened in the
past but if you want to connect to
Twitter live to a given topic it's easy
to set up immediately set up and with
Docker compose in the same way so we do
a Docker compose
um
waiting for it to to get up I will move
to my browser window
um wait a second for
for it to come up and will as the live
replay uh proceeds we will soon be
getting our first tweets this is hello
Adrian yes we are wrapping up we have
around four minutes sorry perfect
perfect that's just perfect
the tweets are coming in in simulated
real time in fact we have a speed up
factor of 50 and as they come in uh you
see the green and violet circles which
represent positive and negative
sentiment V circles update as for total
uh number of tweets increases we're
processing uh about
um several thousand tweets every second
uh and and you see that that the
sentiment changes in this case we are
looking at uh predictors of influence of
a given tweet for example we have some
negative feedback here from Detroit
after Eminem's performance which
apparently was quite controversial
um just to wrap up the interesting
things that are going on inside the
pipeline and pathway versus
pre-processing with filtering joins and
a call to an external API placeholder
there's
um iterative geolocation clean and go
going inside in pathway because for the
locations that we we get
um have some errors with effects like
turn on notifications placed instead of
a place name we use an iterative process
to actually figure out which place names
are kind of suspect we use a bit of
geography and use the intellect
interlinked gov data from from the graph
of interconnected tweets to figure out
which locations are suspected and we
clear them out then we do sentiment
analysis with text blob and compute
influence in fact going Beyond a simple
um predict a simple influence measure
just to get a predictor of which tweets
are likely to create significant Buzz
before this actually happens and the
size of the circles which I was showing
you in the demo are a measure of just
that
so the main takeaway
steaming life had some pains in store
for us there was no time for a coffee
however if you go for pathway if we go
for having our little pause PWS pause in
our code we let you let pathway handle
live data updates for you and things get
easier your code is basically what it
was in the bad sense just with things um
in streaming and at scale
um it's a pleasure to have a chance to
to Premiere with Pathways open Beta uh
it would be a pleasure to have you part
of Pathways Community join us uh on our
website join us on Discord we're there
um so many many thanks for from the
whole team for having us and don't
hesitate to earn examples experiment
have fun with pathway and let us know
what you think
thank you very much
um we can have a quick question
uh it I take it only specific algorithms
are supported for pathway
so pathway allows you to create your own
algorithms Android from in pathway uh
class Transformer Transformer class
syntax allows you to express a lot of
things time series graph algorithms
things like um you'll find things like
like page rank or Bellman Ford and other
golf search algorithms in our in our
library but essentially uh anything that
that would work fast as a distributed
algorithm will work fast in pathway you
implement it in pathway and it it'll run
so anything is supported things that
distribute well uh that will run well in
a distributed architecture will also
most likely be running fast in pathway
thank you very much uh and we will
conclude here thank you for your time uh
thank you looking forward to more
questions of this code thank you so much